of the biggest differences between male
and female psychology the big difference
is men are more aggressive and
risk-taking and women are Kinder and
more nurturing and you don't have to go
to a psychology lab women may be
aggressive in other ways but pure
violence is mostly a male a male
activity the care and nurturance of
children is mostly a female activity
this is true for human is this true for
primates you always got to have the
caveat everywhere in the world is also
true men are taller this does not
preclude the fact that there are some
women taller than average men and some
men shorter than the average woman you
kind of have whenever time a human
difference is maybe it's worth being in
this caveat